mom what are you doing
i'm just punching in some of my friends
don't worry about it they'll be here
hey that's not fair to the employees who
are here on time mom you can't do that
you know what they told me that i
couldn't push out that big head of yours
but i did that too
[Laughter]
finally gonna fix the brakes on your
bike after school
wait is that the lie
wear a helmet
[Laughter]
you know george learned that lying trick
for me what was your lie
oh that we didn't have enough money to
send him to college
you fired me thank you
i'm gonna say something i never said
before
i'm proud of you you had the guts to
fire your own mother they
finally dropped
[Laughter]
you know they don't make hallmark cards
for people like us mom
lunch lady of the past and lunch lady of
the future
we're dyeing our hair yeah now move it
george i need the sun to cook the juices
and your head's making any clips
carmen has a boyfriend and you're still
letting her out of the house um
i got it under control i talked to her
about duncan then we hugged
oh dog that's different that's so sweet
i wish i'd been there with the camera to
take a picture of how stupid you are
why are you in such a good mood today
mom you smoking with a patch on again
hey i have a question yes that sign
outside no smoking
was that just for the kids or for
everybody
that's for everyone how long is the play
just under 20 minutes i'll catch it on
broadway
i don't care what she says i don't think
max is ready to walk to school until he
learns about the real world
i'll tell you what i did when you were a
kid i used to read the newspaper to you
right before bed
remember the zodiac killer you'd say
he's not coming here is he mommy look at
the paper and tell you
it doesn't say i want a chance to get
back in the carpool
state your name you know my name state
your name
this dope will do anything skip around
like a pony and slap your own ass
hey grandma what's up can a grandmother
just visit her granddaughter
you never had before the last time
you're in my room i was in a crib
how can you possibly remember that you
never forget the first time you smell
nicotine in cold 45.
well you know i was just waiting till
you covered every
inch of your walls in stupid posters
i thought i straightened them out last
week i know just what you're going
through
when i was in high school they called me
easy cheap loose
of course i was pregnant
[Applause]
i'm gonna call adam's parents about this
window right now adam didn't do it
piper did piper that snob used to be
your friend
that's her handwriting i know cause she
wrote carmen can't say no pez on my
locker
hey thank god our last name hidden
tucker
what's going on well carmen got in a
fight mom
oh look you got blood on you it's the
other girls
damn my granddaughter's a scrapper
[Applause]
mom we don't encourage violence in this
house
how many years it took me to get your
father's respect and now you want me to
ask him for money cause i kept meeting
my obligations
that's not gonna happen well your pride
is not going to pay for the cosmetics
well i wouldn't have to pay
if max hadn't burned the garage down
wouldn't it burn out if carmen
hadn't taken the battery out of the
smoke detector for her cd
so none of this player have happened if
grandma was watching max instead of
salvador gigante
who gets a job where they have to keep
17 000
worth of beauty crap in the garage i
will tell you who
someone who can't type
i came to phoenix because i wanted to do
this face-to-face
i'll tell you something i never thought
i'd be sitting across from money's first
wife
well you wouldn't be if i thought i
could stomach sitting across from manny
i don't see it what manny left me
for you you know i'm not saying you're
ugly or anything i just don't see
it it's not just math
it's all the subjects he's not getting
it so what happens if he fails the
proficiency test
he gets held back oh you people and your
education
everybody's got to go to college
pizzas don't deliver themselves
grandma check out my plate
isn't that cute i've got a gun now but
it seems like only yesterday i was
sleeping with a knife
morning grandma morning morning dork hey
i told you not to call me that
lame can you tutor him
dad 15 bucks an hour but
you guys paid actually 30.
quiet you don't know math get over here
i guess i could find the time no jason
you said you wouldn't take on any more
activities i can do it in a half hour a
day and
we'll see each other more come on your
little brother needs help in math
fine but max will need to know math for
his job anyway when someone orders a
hamburger he'll just press the hamburger
picture
did you hear that buddy she put you
right up front at the register
somebody believes in you meal
george i got all this money to give away
in my will
i just can't decide if i should give it
to carmen
or max
i'll get you your beer i'll rub your
feet
and we have a winner
you